[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien Ihnen einen guten Abend das
Finale im DFB-Pokal das steht mehr dazu
später mit dir Katja so ist das schönen
guten Abend dann schauen wir jetzt
gemeinsam auf unsere heutigen Themen
kriegstribunal gegen Russland in Den
Haag fordert ukrainespräsident selensky
ein Verfahren ähnlich wie die Nürnberger
Prozesse
auf Kosten der Umwelt werden alle
Menschen so viele Ressourcen verbrauchen
würden wie in Deutschland bräuchte es
drei Planeten
und Niederlage für Gerhard Schröder der
Altkanzler scheitert mit seiner Klage
und hat keinen Anspruch auf ein Büro im
Bundestag
[Musik]
zur mysteriösen drohnenattacke auf den
Kreml ließ Moskau heute folgendes
verlauten Entscheidungen über solche
Angriffe würden nicht in Kiew sondern in
Washington getroffen die beiden
Regierung dementierte umgehen auch
Ukraine ist Präsident selenski weist
jede Schuld von sich und ließ heute beim
Besuch in den Niederlanden aufhorchen er
fordert ein internationales
gerichtsregional um Putin zur
Rechenschaft ziehen zu können
Den Haag internationaler
Strafgerichtshof an diesem Ort sollen
die Kriegsverbrechen bestraft werden
darauf hofft er der ukrainische
Präsident selenski ein Besuch mit klarer
Botschaft Präsident Putin müsse vor
Gericht gestellt werden
jeder Kriegsverbrecher glaubt er müsste
sich niemals für seine Taten vor einem
Gericht rechtfertigen aber es ist für
die internationale Gemeinschaft wichtig
das Kriegsverbrecher sich verantworten
müssen und verurteilt werden
noch sprechen die Waffen und nicht das
Recht die Ukraine plant wohl eine
offensive silenski wird bei seiner
Europa-Tour für mehr Waffenlieferungen
ein Krieg wird mit Waffen gewonnen so
läuft das nun einmal ich bin allen sehr
dankbar für jedes Waffensystem und jede
Munition die sie uns schicken
die Lage spitzt sich zu in Russland
häufen sich die Anschläge auf die
Infrastruktur unter anderem Ziel zwei
treibstofflage für Moskau steckt die
Ukraine dahinter wie auch hinter dem
angeblichen thronenangriff auf dem Kreml
den Russland abwehrte
der ehemalige russische Präsident mit
wedev ein enger Vertrauter Putins
fordert auf Telegramm die physische
Beseitigung von silensky und seiner
Clique silensky weist die Vorwürfe
Moskau zurück und reagiert auf die
Morddrohung der russischen Führung
gelassen
wir wissen zu was sie fähig sind und wir
spüren wie frustriert ihr Land ist und
ihre Soldaten auf dem Schlachtfeld
selenski soll nächste Woche wohl auch
noch nach Deutschland kommen der
Präsident scheint sich noch einmal
Rückendeckung für seine Militär
Offensive zu holen
jetzt nach Berlin zu Theo call Theo
riesen Aufregungen in der Hauptstadt
jemand hat einer Zeitung den Reiseplan
selenskys für Mitte Mai nach Berlin
durchgestochen was bedeutet das jetzt
naja ganz konkret unangenehm dürfte es
für denjenigen Polizeibeamten werden der
die Informationen an eine Berliner
Boulevardzeitung durchgestochen hat denn
jetzt ermittelt das Landeskriminalamt
wegen Geheimnisverrats und peinlich ist
es natürlich auch für silenskys mögliche
Berliner Gastgeber im Kanzleramt denn
selensky gehört nicht wirklich
überraschend zu den am meisten
gefährdeten Menschen der Welt und seine
Reisen werden bis zum letzten Moment
geheim gehalten aus Kia fies ist zwar
heute der Geheimnisverrat könne einen
möglichen Besuch in Frage stellen aber
damit wird hier in Berlin nicht wirklich
gerechnet man dürfte aber natürlich die
bisherige Detailplanung und natürlich
auch das veröffentlichte Hotel verändern
Deutschland gehört ja zu den wenigen
Verbündeten bei denen sie Lenski noch
nicht zu Besuch war und die Auszeichnung
mit dem Aachener Karlspreis an ihn und
an die Ukraine war seit längerem
öffentlich bekannt und wer eins und ein
zusammenzog der konnte natürlich davon
ausgehen dass das der Moment auch für
einen Besuch in Deutschland sein dürfte
danke für die Hintergründe nach berlin-
lange galt Afrika als der vergessene
Kontinent mit seiner zweiten
Afrika-Reise nach 17 Monaten im Amt will
Kanzler Scholz das Gegenteil beweisen
erstes Ziel diesmal
Äthiopien des gerade einen blutigen
Bürgerkrieg um die Region tigrein mit
hunderttausenden Toten erlebt hat von
dort geht es weiter nach Kenia Scholz
weil Partnerschaften stärken und den
Frieden fördern im Fokus auch die
aktuelle Krise im Sudan Susann von
Lojewski und Energie
im Norden Äthiopiens noch immer leiden
die Menschen unter den Folgen des
Bürgerkrieges eine Flüchtlingsunterkunft
reiht sich an die nächste
hunderttausende können weiter nicht
zurück in ihre Heimat Dörfer das
UN-Flüchtlingshilfswerk fürchtet dass
sich die Versorgungslage demnächst noch
weiter verschärfen wird
aufgrund der Krise in Sudan wurden so
viele tausende Menschen vertrieben dass
der Bedarf an humanitärer Hilfe steigen
wird und wir brauchen dringend Mittel zu
Bewältigung dieser Notlage es sind auch
die vielen Krisen auf dem Kontinent die
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz zum zweiten
Mal in seiner Amtszeit nach Afrika
reisen lassen sein Zeitplan ist eng
getaktet die Probleme groß der Krieg im
Sudan hunderttausende Binnenflüchtlinge
der Kanzler besucht zunächst die
Afrikanische Union er will sich dafür
stark machen dass die AU einen Sitz am
Tisch der G20 Länder bekommen Afrika
muss in den
internationalen Beziehungen in der
internationalen Politik eine größere
Rolle spielen eine Rolle die dem
Kontinent und seiner wachsenden
Bedeutung auch gerecht wird
Äthiopiens Ministerpräsident wird das
gerne hören von seinem Abendtermin mit
dem Kanzler gibt es nur Fotos aber wie
Ahmed Friedensnobelpreisträger und dann
Kriegsherr gegen T3 beantwortet nicht
gerne Fragen der Arbeitsbesuch von Olaf
Scholz in Addis Abeba ist kein ganz
einfacher auf der einen Seite ist
Deutschland an einem stabilen Äthiopien
als regional macht interessiert und will
deswegen die Regierung auch weiter
unterstützen auf der anderen Seite muss
auch klar werden dass Präsident Abi
Ahmet sich weiter für Frieden im eigenen
Land einsetzen muss noch heute abend
reißt der Kanzler weiter nach Kenia die
Themen dort sie werden angenehmer sein
es ist ein einmaliger Vorgang in der
bundesdeutschen Geschichte ein
ehemaliger Kanzler klagt gegen den Staat
Gerhard Schröder wegen seiner engen
russland-verbindungen in der Kritik
wollte vor Gericht erzwingen dass er
seine Privilegien zurückhält jetzt
entschied des zuständige Gericht in
Berlin nein Schröder hat keinen Anspruch
auf ein Bundestagsbüro Details von Sarah
Tacke
dieses Büro bekommt er erstmal nicht
wieder 17 Jahre lang konnte Gerhard
Schröder von hier aus seiner
Amtsgeschäfte als Bundeskanzler aD
führen sechs Zimmer samt persönlicher
Mitarbeiter standen ihm zur Verfügung
sowie anderen altkanzleramt zuvor auch
kosten rund 400.000 Euro pro Jahr doch
vor einem Jahr dann strich der
Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestags
Schröder die Ausstattung und zwar
zurecht entschied heute das
Verwaltungsgericht Berlin
der Bundeskanzler ADAC Gerhard Schröder
hat keinen Anspruch auf zur
Verfügungstellung von Stellen für ein
Büro diese Anspruch kann nicht auf
Gewohnheitsrecht gestützt werden
kein Recht auf ein Büro so viel steht
für die Richterinnen und Richter fest
aber sie bemängelt zugleich dass es
überhaupt keine klaren Regeln für
Privilegien von altkanzlern gibt
möglicherweise sieht sich ja der
Gesetzgeber nach Rechtskraft des Urteils
dazu bewogen oder ist bewogen eine neue
gesetzliche Grundlage für diese Thematik
zu schaffen früher das Privilegien
wurden vor gut einem Jahr entzogen als
die Kritik an seinen Verbindung zu Putin
besonders laut war offiziell wurden ihm
zwar nicht deshalb seine Sonderrechte
aber erkannt auch wenn der Bundestag
genau das hätte zum Thema machen können
denn mit dieser Entscheidung ist völlig
klar der Bundestag kann ganz frei
entscheiden welche Altkanzler welche
Privilegien bekommen oder auch nicht er
kann jederzeit auch Privilegien wieder
entziehen wie eine Büroausstattung wie
Mitarbeiter auch aus politischen helfen
allerdings können Schröders Anwälte noch
Berufung einlegen der Rechtsstreit
Ex-Kanzler gegen Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ist also noch nicht zwingend
abgeschlossen
der
SPD-Bundestagsabgeordnete Caramba diabi
ist immer wieder
Opfer rassistischer Attacken jetzt wurde
ein Brandanschlag auf seinen
Wahlkreisbüro in Halle an der Saale
verübt zwei Zeugen hatten den
mutmaßlichen Täter festgehalten bis die
Polizei kam es handelt sich um einen
55-jährigen der der Polizei bekannt ist
schon mehrfach hat die Abi nach eigenen
Angaben Strafantrag gegen den Mann
gestellt auch wegen rassistischer
Beleidigungen
schon länger gibt es Vorwürfe der
Vetternwirtschaft im Grünen geführten
Wirtschaftsministerium jetzt erhöht die
Opposition den Druck und bringt einen
parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss
ins Spiel im Fokus Minister Habeck und
sein Staatssekretär Patrick reichen der
als Kopf der Energiewende gilt reichen
soll seinem Trauzeugen zu einem
Spitzenposten verholfen haben mehr von
Diana zimmermann
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister
ungewöhnlich Kamera Scheu auch heute
vermeidet Robert Habeck Fragen zu seinem
Staatssekretär zu Patrick reichen dem
zweitmächtigsten Mann im
Wirtschaftsministerium sein Stuhl
wackelt ein Kritikpunkt sind reichens
Familienbande seine Geschwister arbeiten
beide im Öko-Institut das Studien für
das Wirtschaftsministerium erstellt die
Opposition spricht von grüner Seilschaft
und fordert reichen zurücktritt wenn
jetzt öffentlich wird dass die
Berechnung die in diesem Ministerium
vorgenommen waren nicht richtig sind
aber von Instituten vorgenommen worden
deren Chefs wiederum verwandt sind mit
den Staatssekretären von Herrn Harbeck
dann zeigt sich eben dass es auch eine
große Gefahr für unser Land ist dass
dort eine kleine Familienbande in der
Meinung ist über das Wohl und Wehe der
deutschen Heizkörper und der deutschen
Industrie zu entscheiden
tatsächlich gibt das Ministerium schon
seit Jahren und auch schon unter
cdu-leitung Studien beim Öko-Institut in
Auftrag und beide Geschwister greifen
haben dort keine leitende Funktion aber
der starke Mann hinter harberg hat noch
ein Problem er saß in der
Findungskommission die seinen Trauzeugen
Michael Schäfer zum neuen Chef der
Deutschen Energieagentur machen wollte
und fand nichts dabei für Harbeck war
reichen bislang eine große Stütze nun
hat er versprochen das Verfahren um die
Energieagentur neu aufzurollen stellt
sich aber sonst vor ihm
ohne die konsequente Art von Patrick
reichen wäre Deutschland heute in einer
schweren Wirtschaftskrise
damit hat Habeck sein Schicksal eng an
das des umweltökonomen geknüpft doch
auch aus der eigenen Koalition kommt
keineswegs nur Unterstützung
für mich gilt dass ich zunächst einmal
davon ausgehe dass alles mit rechten
Dingen zugegangen ist in Herr gleichen
ist bekannt dafür dass er einseitig nur
auf die Wärmepumpe setzt das ist für
mich gegenwärtigen politisches Problem
der Rest wird aufgeklärt
pikante ist das ist die Grünen waren die
jahrelang gegen den schwarzen Filz in
den Unionsparteien wetterten und eine
neue Moral in der Politik forderten nun
gilt wer hoch sitzt kann auch tief
fallen
ab morgen lebt Deutschland auf Pump also
ökologisch betrachtet weil schon heute
hat Deutschland rechnerisch seine
Ressourcen aufgebraucht die uns fürs
gesamte Jahr zur Verfügung stehen
berechnet wird dieser Erd
überlastungstag vom global footprint
Network weltweit liegt Deutschland damit
im oberen Viertel zwar weniger
verschwenderisch als die USA oder
Russland aber schlechter als Frankreich
das Vereinigte Königreich oder China im
weltweiten Durchschnitt wird der
überlastungstag für Juli oder August
erwartet mehr dazu jetzt von Mark Hugo
es gibt sie nur einmal unsere Erde und
doch bräuchten wir drei davon wenn alle
so leben würden wie die Menschen in
Deutschland ab heute ist das deutsche
Budget an natürlichen Ressourcen
eigentlich aufgebraucht die Gründe der
Treibhausgasausstoß sinkt zwar ist aber
immer noch deutlich höher als in den
anderen EU-Ländern vor einem Kohle und
gasschlagen zu Buche aber auch die
intensive Landwirtschaft und im Verkehr
bleibt der Ausstoß von Abgasen seit
Jahren zu hoch
autogerechte Städte uns fehlt ein
bisschen der Mut Städte rumzugestalten
den öffentlichen Personennahverkehr zur
besseren mehr für Rad- und Fußverkehr zu
tun in attraktiver zu machen ein
weiterer Faktor jeden Tag wird für
Straßen und Bebauung eine Fläche neu
ausgewiesen so groß wie 78 Fußballfelder
umweltschützer sehen die Politik in der
Pflicht
wenn wir es schaffen wollen Klimakrise
und Artensterben abzumildern müssen wir
es auch schaffen den Ressourcenverbrauch
Deutschlands um 85 Prozent bis 2050 zu
reduzieren das heißt das ist ein
riesiger Wandel der da vor uns steht und
um den zu meistern brauchen wir
verbindliche Ziele und ein
ressourcenschutzgesetz aber auch jeder
einzelne müsse sich an die eigene Nase
packen in der Summe macht auch sein
Verhalten einen Unterschied weniger
Fleisch ist zum beispielsweise weniger
fliegen weniger Autofahren mehr mit dem
Radfahren mehr zu Fuß gehen kleinere
Autos fahren also angepasster mobil zu
sein da können wir schon einiges tun
einiges tun damit die Erde
überlastungstage künftig immer später
kommen
bei einem Zugunglück nahe Köln sind zwei
Gleisarbeiter ums Leben gekommen sie
waren für die Deutsche Bahn im Einsatz
als der InterCity sie erfasste fünf
ihrer Kollegen mussten den Unfall mit
ansehen und erlitten einen Job etwas 50
Menschen im zugesassen stundenlang fest
während die Polizei spurensicherte der
Grund für das Unglück ist noch völlig
unklar die Bahnstrecke wurde zwischen
Köln und Bonn gesperrt viele Züge
mussten umgeleitet werden
Zinsen hoch Inflation runter das ist der
Kurs von ezb-chefin Lagarde die
Europäische Zentralbank erhöht zum
siebten Mal in Folge die Leitzinsen
jetzt um 0,25 Punkte auf 3,75 Prozent
für Sparer gut für Kreditnehmer schlecht
auch öffentliche Haushalte zählen dazu
und bei ihnen handelt es sich ja um
Steuergeld das jetzt an anderer Stelle
fehlt Stefan Schlösser
mit 4.900 € pro Kopf gehört Darmstadt zu
den hochverschuldeten Städten in
Deutschland die steigenden Zinsen machen
neue Kredite deutlich teurer dennoch
bleibt der Kämmerer vorerst gelassen wir
haben das niedrige Zinsniveau der
letzten Jahre genutzt um langfristig
Vorsorge zu treffen wir haben lange
fristige Kredite abgeschlossen teilweise
mit Laufzeiten von 30 und 50 Jahren und
die Zinsbindung bis ans Ende
festgeschrieben so dass bei diesen
Krediten überhaupt gar keinen
sinnänderungsrisiko besteht und dann
auch die Zinsen nicht schneiden so
vorausschauend war man nicht überall die
zinswände kommt den Bund teuer zu stehen
2021 musste der Finanzminister nur 3,9
Milliarden Euro für Zinsen ausgeben
dieses Jahr sind es fast 30 kommendes
Jahr voraussichtlich 40 Milliarden Euro
zwischen 2014 und 2020 hatten wir die
schwarze Null wir hatten Überschüsse in
dieser Zeit hätten alle
Bundesfinanzminister auch ein
umschuldungsprogramm auflegen müssen mit
dem Ziel dass eben die neuen Schulden
langfristig mit dem niedrigen Zinsen
gesichert werden leider ist das nicht
passiert viel Geld geht für Zinsen drauf
der Handlungsspielraum für wichtige
Vorhaben ist somit eingeschränkt der
Finanzminister Deutschland muss weniger
Ausgaben haben muss die Ausgaben
runterfahren das tut natürlich weh in
einer Zeit wo wir ja mehr für die
wehrtüchtigkeit für Sozialleistungen für
die Infrastruktur für Klimaschutz
ausgeben müssen erst ab 2024 plant
Darmstadt mit neuen Schulden dann trifft
auch sie die Zinswende
so jetzt zum Sport die Ansetzung im
DFB-Pokalfinale die steht Katja ja so
sieht es aus gesucht wurde der zweite
Finalist neben RB Leipzig und gefunden
wurde Eintracht Frankfurt durchatmen
beim Team und Trainer Oliver Glasner die
zuletzt nicht wirklich auf der
Erfolgsspur waren jetzt aber Endspiel
nach einem 3:2 beim VfB Stuttgart
Erleichterung beim in der Kritik
stehenden Frankfurter Trainer Classen
der Pokalfinale seine Eintracht ist mal
wieder dabei aber gestern ging es
erstmal gut los für den Gegner führungs
Stuttgart nach 20 Minuten die zweite
Halbzeit dann ein Frankfurter Sturmlauf
innerhalb von vier Minuten treten sie
das Spiel Ausgleich ein dicker 51 Minute
2:1 Führungstreffer kamada 55 und in der
77 minute verwandelte kolonia nie einen
Strafstoß Spiel durch nein der VfB mit
dem anschluss-treffer und dann letzte
Szene des Spiels Check eines Frankfurter
Handspiels Entscheidung korrekt kein
Elfer gewinnt genauso gehört sich dass
es sich in so eine Entscheidung quasi
ansieht und dann eine Entscheidung
trifft dafür ist der Feuer gut und
deswegen ja waren wir dann natürlich
dann riesen Klumpen runtergefallen
Frankfurt auch in dieser Saison mit
einer Titel Chance im Pokalfinale
auf eine Titel Chance auf der ATP-Tour
muss Tennisprofi Daniel Altmaier weiter
warten er ist im Viertelfinale beim
Masters in Madrid ausgeschieden nach
einer 3:6 3:6 Niederlage gegen den
kroatenborner Jovic dennoch ein
Ausrufezeichen des 24-Jährigen
zu den besten 8 Spielern bei einem ATP
Masters Turnier gehört zu haben wird für
Daniel Altmaier zeitlebens eine kostbare
Erinnerung bleiben gegen den Kroaten
Borna Zurich die Nummer 20 der
Weltrangliste hatte der 24-Jährige
allerdings von Beginn an kaum eine
Chance nach nur einem Break ging der
erste Satz mit sechs zu drei an den
überlegenden Kroaten das schlagrepertoir
Altmeyer sorgte nur gelegentlich für
direkte Punkte und viel zu selten gelang
es ihm seinen Gegner zu überraschen nach
75 Minuten konnte Bernhardt sondern
Einzug ins Halbfinale feiern in dem
Morgen der Spanier Carlos auf ihn wartet
ja heute abend hat Lennart aber noch die
chancenviertelfinale gegen den Griechen
Stephanus zieht sie passt gut
ausgesprochen danke Katja Schauer und
Gewitter ziehen auf wann es Wehen wie
heftig trifft gleich von Katja horneffer
im heute journal um 21:45 Uhr empfängt
sie später Maria das lomka das war die
19 Uhr heute am Donnerstag schönen Abend
für Sie und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt ändert sich das Wetter
und das liegt an diesem Tief dass über
die Bretagne weiter nach Großbritannien
zieht die Luft wird von Südwesten schwül
und in der zweiten Nachthälfte setzen
dann Regenschauer und Gewitter im Westen
ein sonst ist es noch trocken und zum
Teil auch klar wie an der Donau und dort
wird es kalt dort sinken die
Temperaturen bis vier Grad unter den
Schauer und Gewitterwolken im Westen
bleibt es milder bei 14 bis 10 Grad die
Höchsttemperatur morgen liegen bei 16
bis 24 Grad und nur an der Ostsee ist es
mit 10 bis 11 Grad deutlich kälter das
liegt dort immer noch am kräftigen
Ostwind der hält die Wolken ein bisschen
auf Distanz Regenschauer und Gewitter
aus der Nacht ziehen allmählich weiter
auswärts verkleckern dabei aber immer
mehr so das westlich des Rheins häufiger
wieder die Sonne zum Vorschein kommt im
Osten ist es morgen Vormittag am
freundlichsten und am Nachmittag bleibt
es das auch noch in Nordosten sonst aber
brodelt ist in der Atmosphäre das
brauchen sich kräftige Schauer und
Gewitter zusammen mit zwei Schwerpunkten
zum einen hier in Nordrhein-Westfalen im
südlichen nieder wachsende nördlichen
Hessen und zum anderen im Alpenvorland
es können in einzelnen Gewittern
durchaus 30 bis 50 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter zusammenkommen es gibt auch
Sturmböen und Hagel der Samstag wird
etwas ruhiger der Sonntag bringt dann
neue Unwetter guten Abend